why'd you move to Houston
a girl
I got divorced what do you mean I got
divorced a few years ago yeah you have
children with her with my wife ex-wife
yeah yeah we got we had two kids why are
you why are you doing this I thought you
followed me from afar and you don't have
children I didn't see the kids in the
binoculars YouTube broke up yeah yeah
and then why did why did you look like
Troy Aikman if he was in a microwave I
get that a lot yeah yeah I get a mix I
get I get Troy Aikman yeah yeah bit from
Back to the Future and Tommy from Power
yeah those are three yeah you have a
yeah a thing going on I do yeah you like
it
yeah yeah and so you have two kids from
your previous marriage yeah and then you
guys moved to Houston
divorce
and I moved to Houston I mean the real
reason I was moving anyways like I was
we were living in uh the Bay Area and I
was like we I we had to avoided I had
avoid a process server for about five
months
so we had we had two residences we had
one in Ohio and one in California uh I
filed in Ohio and then she avoided the
process server and filed in California
wow so we I mean we was on the run her
and me it was it was cat and mouse game
you guys have a relationship now you
were cordial good you know she got
served and uh so divorce happened in
Ohio which is way better okay for for me
yeah I mean just that's what it is
that's where you're from right yeah well
I mean that's where we live though
that's where we voted that's where we
paid taxes there was an ad cab secret
agenda when I filed for divorce I was
like no I got to do what's legal and we
legally live in Ohio and then we even
though we had a house in California but
when we built the house of California I
literally asked my accountant and
everybody said we can still have an Ohio
residency right because I didn't want to
pay California taxes uh I didn't want to
go through all that [__] so I was like
they said yeah yeah you're a comedian as
long as you stay half the time in Ohio
now halftime California you're fine and
I'm always on the road so I would split
my time so wow and then you then you
moved to Houston no state taxes in Texas
no Texas state taxes why don't you go to
Austin like everyone else well they
don't have a hub I travel every week so
Houston has the two hubs so I can get
anywhere direct you know what I mean
you're just constantly on the road yeah
you like it
I mean it's it's getting to be a little
more now I'm at a place at least I can
pick and choose where I want to go yeah
like I don't have to go to Fort Wayne
Indiana yeah you have to go to Des
Moines for four days yeah you know what
I mean yeah because all my life that's
all I remember is being in some weird
City you know I mean on a weekend it's
so depressing is it to me it was was it
yeah yeah because to me it was like
because when you're like 10 15 years in
and then you're in like I love El Paso
yeah man do you yeah
interesting of all cities you're the
first person
you know and it's funny you say that
that was my first ever Road gig at a
comedy club and I drove part read I
drove from San Diego to El Paso yeah now
you remember David Arnold right
no shut up
I need to say something about him
I love him yeah I miss him so much yeah
what a great [__] guy
um well he's one of the reasons I got
back in The Comedy Store
so what happened on the the six seven
months I was out I tore my ACL
I had knee surgery his ex-wife
was uh was doing my paperwork at Balboa
Hospital in San Diego so under cubicle
she had all these pictures of David up
all these articles and I go is your
husband a comedian she uh I'm a comedian
and then she goes she I go I go he's
like on the road she's yeah she gives me
his number I call him he goes yo you got
to get a head shot you gotta get a bio
you gotta get a resume I said all right
what year was this
so in those six months I'm doing like
little open mics uh in in the black
rooms yeah but you know you only get a
couple minutes and you're only dealing
with us uh black people yeah so your
comedy isn't really expanded like it
should so he calls me man I got these
head shots I typed up this fake resume I
remember I said I opened up for Jim
Carrey at a cancer uh charity event
you know yeah you know so then I I start
sending them out you got to send a VHS
tape out with your head shot and your
bio and [__] bark read responded no
way wow he goes yeah we want you
Thursday through Sunday we'll give you
500 bucks for the weekend no travel
you're staying at the condo with the
other two comics and I was like all
right got off work on Thursday at
fielding a got off uh on on got off on
Friday somehow I got off I remember I
droved El Paso got there right for the
show and I just remember I wasn't making
no money so I remember I bought a a box
of Cocoa Puffs and a gallon of milk that
was breakfast yeah Arby's had the two
beef and cheddars yeah
lunch yeah and then I'd eat dinner at
the club wow and I was like so I spent
less than probably 20 bucks on food
it was good yeah yeah I was like you
have to do that is that how it worked
back then is that you would have to
submit your resumes to clubs oh yeah oh
yeah it wasn't online you had a VHS tape
yeah oh whoa and a lot of times I don't
think they wash the teeth they probably
just read your bio and resume yeah you
know and then hopefully word of mouth I
mean I had an agent
but in the very beginning
I did it I did it that way but you know
but yeah some people
I just call my Jew
I call the Jews and I go hey help me out
here
you know
I did that yeah yeah I mean I did all
that was Vegas your first road gig that
was impossible yeah and I did five
minutes
who else is on that show wild Willie
Parsons